we're going to be reviewing the advanced
exam paper today and we're going to go
through it in a lot of a detail so for
any of these questions where you feel
like oh I get this I didn't have any
issues with it or I'm pretty confident I
understand it feel free to skip forward
and go to the sections that are relevant
to you now rather than go through the
entire paper from the start to the
finish I am going to do every question
but rather than do it in sequential
order I'm gonna do it by topic order so
you can see here we've got statistics
then differential calculus then integral
calculus which were the big topics that
were covered in this assessment task so
we're gonna go through each of them in
turn will do all the stats questions all
the differential calculus and then we'll
finish with the integration so as you
can see here that means I'm not gonna
jump into question one I'm gonna jump in
at question four we'll do a few they're
moving to the extended response and
we'll pick up things as we go along so
let's have a go at question for this is
the first stats question the
stem-and-leaf plot below represents the
daily sales of toilet paper very
relevant information and timely as you
can see if the range is 43 what is the
sample standard deviation correct two
decimal places so there's a couple of
things going on in this question which
is a bit sneaky because even though
you'd have to do a fair bit of work here
you only have one mark because it's
multiple twice so let's try and chip
away at this first on is the first curve
ball that's thrown at you is that this
data set isn't complete or at least
there's a bit of an unknown which you
have to kind of work out you can see
there on the stem-and-leaf plot you've
got that X there we don't know what that
is but we can use the other information
in the question provided to us to work
out what it is the question says let's
get a good color here the range is 43 so
if the range is known to be 43 you have
a think about well what's the way in
which I calculate the range it's the top
value takeaway the bottom values so in
this case I can see what my top value is
it's going to be 77 so I can say that
that's a 77 takeaway and then you
subtract your bottom value which in this
this would be I mean I guess I would
read it as 30x
but that's not the way I would write it
because if I wrote 30 X that would be 30
times X if I had some figure like 35
what I really mean is it's 30 plus 5 not
30 times 5 so as a consequence I'm gonna
say the top value is 77 the bottom value
is 30 plus X that will give me my range
but I already know that that's going to
be 43 so I can use just a bit of
algebraic manipulation to work out
what's going on here
I'll expand these brackets 77 take away
30 take away X equals 43 77 take away 30
is 47 take away X and you can see pretty
clearly now if I rearrange this let's
just do it for completeness sake
and subtract 47 from both sides I'm
gonna get negative x equals negative 4
so that gives me the value that I
actually need so this X over here let's
use the appropriate color that's
actually a 4 so now I know my entire
data set and I have to use that to work
out these sample standard deviations so
we switch over here I've got my
calculator here running and I'm just
gonna walk you through really quickly in
case you can't remember how to get
sample standard deviation how you can go
about calculating that I always begin
because I'm slightly paranoid by
clearing out whatever data was already
stored in the calculator generally you
know you'll be fine inputting data but
just in case you did a question before
this and there's some other data points
floating around you don't want them to
confuse the calculation you're doing now
so I'm gonna go through and I'm gonna
say 3 for all and then I'm going to say
yep I want to clear everything all right
so everything is clear now in order to
get into statistical moon I hit set up I
press 2 for stat
and as usual we have all our different
choices for what kind of data we want to
input if you have a look closely here
this stem-and-leaf plot only has single
scores this is not bivariate data it's
just a single variable that we're
comparing so that's why I'll hit one for
one variable and now you can see I can
improve my score so let's real quick
do that I put in the 35 which I got from
working that out from the range I hit 35
35 was the example I gave I went 34
that's what I calculated hit equals and
I'm gonna keep on doing this for all of
my score so I'm going to go 36 I need to
enter 36 twice because it appears twice
in the stem-and-leaf plot 44 48 48 again
49 50 54 57 60 371 and 77 equals okay so
I think I put in all my data I'm just
gonna do a quick check because it's
pretty easy if you're reading the
numbers and sort of just pressing to
keep have without looking closely to
miss enter one of the numbers like maybe
you just didn't press hard enough or you
press the number twice without doing
that intentionally so I'm just going to
double check and make sure that I have
all the right data points there they
look pretty good to me okay so I can
press clear to get out of that all my
data is still saved and I look carefully
to see what calculation they actually
want me to perform what measure it's the
sample standard deviation so it's in
order to get that I'm gonna go down to
my keypad I'm gonna go shift and then
where the one used to be you can see
above that it says that so that gives me
all of these statistical options here
the one that we want to go to is for a
variable and you can see there's
actually two different kinds of standard
deviation that you can calculate and
this is something we don't do all that
frequently so you may have forgotten one
firstly is the number of things there
two is x-bar which is the main but three
and four are the standard deviations
which one is the right one well three is
the population standard deviation you
can see that's meant to be a Greek
letter there in front of the X in order
to get the sample standard deviation
that's what the S on number four stands
for so I'm going to hit 4 and when I
press equals I get my value out there
thirteen point one four nine so you can
see that
it's going to line up with part beep
that's on a Part B rather answer B I
guess so
that's the closest one well I mean it
round it off so we're good to go
all right so happy times there's a lot
of work just for the first question
let's move on to number 5 which is
merciful a bit simpler